[Musik]
gar nicht vorstellen was sich hier
abgespielt haben muss es muss fahrrad
todeskampf gewesen sein einer der
drastischsten fehler der im rahmen
dieser entwicklung der polizei
unterlaufen ist zu dem zeitpunkt absolut
nicht damit gerechnet dass dieser fall
sich mal wirklich in meiner
mentalen konstellation so stark
auswirken würde er ist ja am ende auch
der punkt gewesen der mich dazu gebracht
hat den beruf es war eine
vermisstenmeldung nach einer jungfrau
und da bin ich schon ein komisches
bauchgefühl manchmal anders als reporter
dass man sagt hier kommt da etwas
komisch vor und damals habe ich schon zu
meiner chefin gesagt die sehen wir nicht
mehr lebend wieder
[Musik]
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
[Musik]
im september 2015 geht die junge frau
namens judith heißen in den klosterwald
um den frühen spätsommerabend ausklingen
zu lassen was sie nicht weiß es wird der
letzte tag ihres lebens sein mein name
ist sky dumont und ich begrüße euch zu
einer neuen ausgabe von tatort
deutschland diesmal mit einem immer noch
unaufgeklärten mordfall einem cold case
was geschah mit der jungen judith heißen
und warum ist ihr tod noch heute ein
skandal der deutschen polizei geschichte
bild reporter karl heim begleitet den
fall von anfang an er sitzt an seinem
schreibtisch in der bild redaktion
hannover die unterlagen zu judith
theissen sind bereits aufgeschlagen ich
weiß ganz genau wie von diesem fall
erfahren habe es war ihm kurz vor
redaktionsschluss
dann gegen kurz vor 18 uhr eine
polizeimeldung auftauchte das war eine
vermisstenmeldung nach einer jungfrau
und dadurch ein komisches bauchgefühl
manchmal anders als reporter was man
sagt sie kommt dann irgendwie komisch
vor und damals habe ich schon zu meiner
chefin gesagt die sehen wir nicht mehr
lebend wieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach der tat haben möchte ich auch
studieren im umfeld des opfers wurde als
eher freundlich beschrieben die menschen
immer sehr herzlich sehr offen wir haben
uns damals immer die hose wahlgeschenken
wer hat im blick getötet und ich fahre
ja mal wieder warum musste jesus sterben
wer war judith theissen um das
herauszufinden macht sich karl heim auf
den weg nach rehbock block um im
landkreis nienburg
der dortige kloster wald ist ein
mächtiger und auch teils beunruhigende
ort riesige baumgruppen bereit sich
aneinander wodurch eine düstere
atmosphäre entsteht genau an dieser
stelle trifft der bild reporter auf den
vater des opfers johannes teyssen der
mittlerweile weißhaarige schaut ernst
richtung kloster wald zieht die beige
regenjacke enger bevor er dem reporter
die hand schüttelt danke noch mal dass
sie die kraft finden auch hier in diesen
ort zurück zu kommen ja gut was macht
das mit ihnen wie man jetzt darüber
nachdenkt jetzt auch noch sechs jahre
danach
man denkt immer wieder dran da wird man
nie verstehen
muss man muss noch nicht weiterleben und
positiv denken man muss auch mal wieder
spaß haben
jetzt ist ja sechs jahre weiter und es
ist immer noch nicht vorbei können sie
mir noch magazin wer war judith vis war
sie eigentlich dass sie war gelernte
bibliothekare die in hannover und die
bibliothek ist geschlossen worden und da
30 arbeitslos erst mal zwei monate um
nachzudenken was sie ihnen machern
willen und ist dann drauf gekommen
sozialpädagogik studieren und als mensch
als tochter weiß ich dass sie sehr
naturverbunden war und sich mit ihrer
ausbildung das war hier sehr wichtig
dass sie weiter im linken haben sich gut
verstanden oder gab es streit zwischen
eltern und kindern gibt es ja manchmal
streiten ja klar ich meine es gibt noch
einmal
dass man sie gut einige sehen vor allem
als kind frühjahr aber nach meiner
scheidung habe ich sehr lange nicht mehr
gesehen also weniger und sie war in
ihrer mutter zusammen
[Musik]
um sich ein noch klareres bild davon zu
machen wer judith als mensch war steht
karl kein den ehemaligen wohnort des
opfers an es ist eine überschaubare
wohngegend in der man sich täglich grüßt
hier in dem haus auf der linken seite
hat im ersten stock gewohnt dass es ihr
balkon
seiner wohnung hier
und wenn man jetzt hier ein bisschen
weiter geht s da hinten ist ein haus da
wohnt die zeugen die sie mutmaßlich
zuletzt lebend gesehen hat die nachbarin
frau lammers eine frau mit grauen
kurzhaarschnitt und brille begrüßt den
bild reporter vor ihrer haustür und
kannten sie jetzt eigentlich
nicht ganz so lange hier sie waren
freundliche junge nachbarin so man
kannte sich eigentlich nur mehr oder
weniger das grüßen und entweder für sie
hat hier mit dem auto vorbei oder sie
war ja dann zwischendurch einmal
erkrankt ist da hab ich mal irgendwie
operiert worden und dann gehen sie hier
mm lang am haus und dann hat man eben
freundlich hallo gesagt oder mal wird
das so irgend so ein gespräch im garten
zahn halten aber wie war sie so ein
fröhlicher mensch oder immer nett oder
gab es auch mal in sich gekehrt
freundlich und hatte immer ein lächeln
irgendwie für jeden der judith kennt ist
es ein schock doch wie muss es sich für
die eltern anfühlen wenn die eigene
tochter plötzlich vermisst wird karl
heim erinnert sich zurück an das
gespräch mit johannes teyssen im mit
erinnerungen übersäten welt und wann
haben sie nicht
gerade arm jung 17 uhr 87 mio gar nicht
meine meine frau kann irgendwer sind sie
gleich von etwas ganz schlimm
ausgegangen oder haben sie erst mal
gedacht okay die ist einfach weg und
kommt vielleicht doch noch wieder nein
lkws mal gedacht lass sie natürlich
presse in die schulen und das sie
gedacht hat okay edelmann paar tage aus
wann kam der polizei ins spiel sind sie
zur polizei gegangen oder ist die mutter
zur polizei gegangen
ihre mutter zur polizei
vermisstenanzeige machen
in dieser lauen spätsommernacht im jahr
2015 kommt judith die eigentlich nur im
nahegelegenen kloster wald spazieren
will nicht mehr nach hause sie in der
list keine nachricht und niemand weiß zu
dem zeitpunkt wo sie sich befindet die
nachbarin frau lammers ist bis heute die
person die judith zuletzt lebend gesehen
hat
damals kann man sehr relativ plötzlich
von julias verschwinden erfahren wie
ging das damals los ich weiß gar nicht
mehr dass welcher wochentag das war wir
waren jedenfalls unterwegs und kam
zurück und da musste ich noch mit den
hunden umgehen und da stand da die
polizei und ja wie das so ist er fragt
man halt was ob irgendwas passiert ist
und da wurde nur einfach gesagt ja die
judith wird vermisst und da hatte ich
damals noch gesagt ich hab dir aber noch
gesehen an dem samstag der ehemalige
polizeibeamte inge mabuse ist damals
einer der beteiligten ermittler bis
heute lässt ihn der fall von judith
nicht los er ist bereit seine
erfahrungen zu teilen denn für ihn hat
dieser fall eine ganz besondere
bedeutung ich war bis vor drei jahren
polizeibeamter ich habe damals in dem
fall juni theissen nicht gearbeitet als
ermittler zu dem zeitpunkt absolut nicht
damit gerechnet dass dieser fall sich
mal wirklich in meiner
mentalen konstellation so stark
auswirken würde er ist ja am ende auch
der punkt gewesen der mich dazu gebracht
hat den beruf zu finden die bei einer
vermisstenmeldung und reagiert die
polizei grundsätzlich auf jeden fall das
ist auch ihre absolute verpflichtung
denn man muss ja weil die winter land
vielleicht auch nur eine
gefahrensituation für leib oder leben
vornehmen könnte das ganze prüfen dann
wird beurteilt ist das sehr
wahrscheinlich dass da in irgendeiner
weise was
jetzt sein könnte dass die person nicht
tatsächlich einfach nur mal ein paar
tage untergetaucht ist oder sich auf
einer reise befindet je konkreter
hinweise sind wo sich die gesuchte
person aufhalten könnte desto einfacher
wird das natürlich wenn man so wie bei
spezielle judith war bei der ersten
mitteilung gar keine hinweise hat wo
könnte die person überhaupt sein dann
ist es sehr still richten bei youtube
ist man dann halt relativ schnell auf
dazu übergegangen dass man sich
zumindest die wohnung mal angeguckt hat
mit den nächsten angehörigen gesprochen
hat problem zu sehen da muss verstehen
nicht was passiert sein womit keiner
gerechnet hat das auto ist dann lockern
gefunden worden stand da person ist
nicht da judith fährt einen kleinen
roten viert ein auffälliger wagen den
man ihr leicht zuordnen kann um zum wald
zu kommen fährt sie mit dem wagen vor
doch die fahrt nach hause tritt sie nie
an natürlich macht man sich dann auch
schon wesentlich mehr sorgen und dann
beginnen da die suchmaßnahmen das auto
stand auf dem parkplatz am kloster und
dadurch hat sich natürlich erschlossen
dass man irgendwo im bereich des
gesamten kloster weist nach judith
suchen kann aber speziell in welchem
stück eben dann nicht wenn es ist ein
riesen suchgebiet also in den folgetagen
ist suche mit den kunden gelaufen es
gibt einige teiche im wald sind auch
damals die suchaktion stattgefunden
haben zum teil abgetaucht abgesucht
worden und da ist auch wasser abgelassen
worden aber es sind wenig konkrete
suchmaßnahmen durch die polizei in den
ersten tagen gelaufen
der vater hat die familie aktiviert der
vater hat also mit abstand am meisten
besucht er ist jeden tag unterwegs
gewesen auch bei schlechten wetter um
möglichst schnell auf eine spur zu
kommen liegt es natürlich nahe sich an
die familie der vermissten zu wenden die
wollen irgendwelche kleidung haben
für diesen spürhund da wollen die im
wald mit gespür und durch ein wald aus
ja da ich meine natürlich ganz stillen
und denken was ist da nur los da muss
man sich jedes mal
[Musik]
durch finden ja warten was man davon
halten soll bald als auswahl komplett
trends für mich ich bin immer noch nicht
von einem verbrechen ausgegangen bin
einfach nur unfall oder
ich weiß es nicht etwas was ich gedacht
habe keine ahnung aber sie haben auch
selbst gesucht sie haben das nicht nur
ein ja ich habe dann die polizei und
gesagt ob ich selber auch im wald suchen
kann und wir haben gesagt hatte ich
nicht aber zu hause mit da kann ich
nicht zu hause herumsitzen also da
hatten sie damals eine hoffnung die
tochter ist plötzlich weg da muss man ja
irgendwie was denken was hoffen
vielleicht ist ja doch irgendwo
mitrollen weg oder so
hoffen darauf dass man natürlich aber
für mich eine aufgabe hängt muss ja
meine tochter finden er die polizei da
sucht okay vielleicht sucht ja auch ich
habe es nicht gesehen aber die werden
das so machen nämlich ein klar als sie
hineingegangen sind damals an dem
zwanzigsten dass sie sie hier tod finden
oder mit mehrheit hat wahrlich nicht
klar das war mir nicht klar ich habe
eine vermutung gab dass sich hier was
unternehmen muss ich musste hier suchen
sie wird hier irgendwo sein vielleicht
liegt sie hier vielleicht die krank
geworden weil sie umgefallen oder
irgendwas aber das hier ermordet worden
ist diese gedanken habe ich nicht gab
also ich ja durch diese durch das
gestrüpp gelaufen bin an die wollen wir
weiter habe ich auf einmal diese diese
ganzen haufen mit esther gesehen hier
die so längst hin gelegt worden sind
dann nicht mehr so bin ich gekommen weil
ich dass ich das nicht natürlich dann
ist man jemand hin gelegt worden da hab
ich mir da so
angeguckt und da sehe ich auch schon
gedichte dran und dass ich so oder
fliegen
hoch und runter ich denke da ist doch
etwas danach wie auch gleich an der
seite gesehen großer platz alles die
getrampelt das kommt dann mache ich
diese inter-star was gewesen ist ein
zelt gestanden hatte und daher nicht
also ist das stück sie noch grob und
dann habe ich die leichnam entdeckt und
dann kriegt man natürlich erstmal
schauen dass man dieses für mich sie
gesicht sehen also ab sofort charakter
dann ist meine dort nicht die polizei
findet die leiche von judith tyson im
kloster wald sondern ihr eigener vater
versteckt unter einer mit efeu
bewachsenen bürkl
für den vater besteht von der ersten
sekunde an kein zweifel dass es sich
hierbei um seine tochter handelt auch
für inge marcuse ist es ein besonders
einprägsam moment gewesen
ein komisches gefühl gewesen wo man den
anruf erhalten hatten muss zum dienst
fahren die mordkommission uns aufgerufen
ich habe mir das ganze vielleicht mehr
zu herzen genommen diese ganzen
ermittlungen und judith theissen damals
weil ich bei dieser jungen frau so eine
ausgeprägte unschuld gesehen habe sie
erschien mir dann auch in der in der
betrachtung der person so so so
unschuldig so unbedarft irgendwo und
dadurch hat sich das für mich persönlich
dann als solche tragik dargestellt das
unrecht einfach so stark dargestellt dh
das hat mich natürlich auch wo dann auch
besonders motiviert vielleicht hat das
aber auch manchmal den blick ein
bisschen verklärt der ehemalige polizist
steht vor der stelle an der die leiche
gefunden wurde er streift über die
seltsam geformte birke und erinnert sich
an den besagten arten zurück wir sind
jetzt hier am tatort im engeren sinne
das heißt dieser welt bereich in dem
befindet sich dann der sogenannte tatort
donner der unmittelbare tatort der
damalige leichenfundort und daneben auch
die stelle an der
wahrscheinlich die tat stattgefunden hat
während dann der leichen von dort einige
meter weiter im endeffekt einfach nur
eine kleine senke in der dann vielleicht
abgelegt worden ist und dann soweit
material zur verfügung stand da zweige
und blattwerk gräser drauf gelegt worden
sind die kollegen von der
kriminaltechnik haben damals diese
gleichen fundstelle dann ganz akribisch
geordnet quasi wenig sagen aufgeräumt
sie haben also zwei schritte von dem
leichnam entfernt ganz sorgfältig das
alles dann langsam weggenommen und alles
dokumentiert da wurde dann auch im
endeffekt jeder zweig genau angeguckt
und da ist dann dem abstand von wenigen
metern einmal speziell dieses papier
stückchen gefunden worden
also doch noch einige andere
gegenstände gefunden worden die dann
eben auf dna untersucht
die spurensicherung ist in dem fall sehr
gut und sehr gründlich auch passiert der
subjektive beigeschmack der kam
judith ist anfang zwanzig lustig
fröhlich und steht mitten im leben sie
hat keine feinde keine massiven schulden
und führt auch keine toxische
gewaltvolle beziehung wer also soll ein
motiv haben diese nette junge frau
umzubringen
[Musik]
nach dem auffinden des leichnams war es
ja dann wichtig erst mal festzustellen
wann genau hat sie noch geliebt
wichtiger punkt war damals auch das
handy was eben am 12 september dann um
15 uhr unter vier minuten
ausgegangen ist rücktritt gedacht hat
man eben die zeit genommen wo sie
verschwunden ausgehend davon dass das
auto hier in loccum auf dem marktplatz
steht an gedrückt wo könnte es eventuell
kameras geben hat die ganzen
möglichkeiten neben abgeklappert überall
gefragt und da wo dann kamera aufnahmen
waren die daneben erbeten das hier ist
die loccumer classic tankstelle an
dieser tankstelle haben wir gefragt ob
kameraaufnahmen da sind das wurde bejaht
wenn man also von hier relativ gute
kamera aufnahmen bekommen tatsächlich
auf den aufnahmen der überwachungskamera
sieht man judith mit ihrem auto
vorfahren und sie steigt aus und kehrt
kurze zeit später nach einem besuch in
der tankstelle zurück sie trägt ein
legeres outfit jeans und t shirt und
ihre haare hat sie zu einem
pferdeschwanz zusammengebunden
die dann tatsächlich so
so kleines rotes auto abgestellt hat und
dann ins geschäft gegangen ist und da
dann
zumindest tabak kaufen wollte und es gab
halt einige aufnahmen auch noch die sie
dann gezeigt haben wie sie zum auto geht
und dann entstand der eindruck dass sie
sich über das sache hinweg mit jemandem
unterhalten hat
aber es gab eben weil die kamera ist
entsprechend eingestellt sind keine
aufnahmen darf und wer dass es
vielleicht gewesen sein könnte ob das so
war oder ob sie nur sich einen moment
irgendwo umgeschaut hat das war dann
eben alles irgendwo nicht mehr so
richtig nachzuvollziehen und jetzt war
es im konkreten fall von lydia so dass
man am ende zum einen ein einkaufs punkt
vom rossmann ja gefunden hat woran man
dann erkennen konnte okay sie hat er
dort eingekauft und das auto ist dann an
dem donnerstag vor dem auffinden der
leiche auf dem marktplatz in lockeren
gefunden worden stand da gepackt und zu
kann man so nach und nach diese ganzen
zeit hinweise immer stärker eingrenzen
reporter karl heim läuft den
überschaubaren marktplatz von loco markt
judith ehemalige nachbarin frau lammers
begleitete ihn er hat judith ihre
letzten einkäufe gemacht
das ging dann wirklich sehr nahe waren
ja nur wusste dass sie das wirklich so
ein junger mensch gewesen ist und dann
macht man sich wirklich gedanken gemacht
fragt sich doch wirklich auch etwas ist
doch passiert ohne warum wersal können
die die situation beschreiben in der sie
judith zuletzt gesehen haben wo sie
damals auf waren ja ich war ja bei uns
im garten auf der terrasse und da schon
die judith verweilen das sind das erste
mal sie kam von zu hause und dann kamen
sie ein paar minuten später ich sag
jetzt mal ein paar minuten später ich
kann mich da auch nicht mehr festlegen
glaube es war kam sie wieder zurück
das sah so aus dass wenn sie etwas
vergessen hatte
und ja und dann vor sicher wieder weg
und das war eingesetzten wagen war sie
am 1 sie hatte dann jemand im auto
können sie beschreiben wie der mann
ausgesehen hat nein das kann ich ja
ähnlich einer bestrahlung ich weiß nur
dass jemand im auto gesessen hat aber
nicht mehr dann einfach dass sie sich
nicht beschreiben ich kann mich da
wirklich gar nicht gar nicht festlegen
da will ich mich auch gar nicht
festlegen die polizei danach ja auch
alles mögliche unternommen bis hin zur
hypnose
ich bekomme es einfach nicht mehr karl
keimen wild tiefer in die polizei
ermittlungen einsteigen er und in gemüse
treffen sich um sich über den fall
auszutauschen guse fährt mit dem wagen
vor und begrüßt den mann der mindestens
so viel anteil an dem fall nimmt wie er
selbst
er trägt ein schwarz rot kariertes hemd
und eine gefütterte dunkle weste darüber
mit einem festen händedruck begrüßte den
report ja ich bin jetzt hier in bad
driburg ich warte auf immer guse er war
damals einer der führenden ermittler in
diesem fall hat er den tiefsten league
wusste ganz genau welche spuren werden
verfolgt und ich hoffe nur dass er mir
erklären kann was er damals passiert ist
hayabusa
danke dass ich zeit klappt das ja gerne
stadtmodell klostermann mama
die beiden männer setzten sich in den
wagen und fahren los während der fahrt
schweigt sie anfangs noch und schauen
durch die frontscheibe in den trüben
himmel bevor der retorte das gespräch
beginnt wächst wohnen ist dann die
polizei konkret nachgegangen man hat
natürlich vermutet dass es sich um ein
sexualdelikt handeln könnte und da wäre
natürlich eine eine beziehung zu einer
platte zu einer männlichen person so
oder so interessant gewesen polizei ist
natürlich beziehung die juden in der
vergangenheit hatte nachgegangen
ex-freunde es gab da zumindest zwei zu
denen auch ganz gut aufgenommen worden
ist dann gab es eine person die sich mit
dem vornamen christ bezeichnet hat die
eine ich sage mal eine virtuelle
beziehung zu judith geführt hat was
ich sag mal relativ mysteriös erschienen
ist weil zu dieser person zwar fotos
vorhanden waren und es gab auch brief
bzw e-mail-verkehr und chat verkehr also
die person dahinter steckt kein mann
sondern eine frau die in irgendeiner
weise dann ja offensichtlich freude oder
lust oder auch noch spannungen daran
empfunden hat so eine ja so eine fake
beziehung einzugehen allerdings musste
man dann im laufe der entwicklung
feststellen dass die personen das
definitiv nicht gewesen ist es gab im
endeffekt auch
die polizei tappt im dunkeln
in anbetracht der entwicklung des falls
werden bestimmte schlussfolgerungen
gezogen
schlussfolgerungen die zu einem
mutmaßlichen täter führen mit dem wohl
keiner gerechnet hat
mit aussuchen verdacht auf mord
was wir dann da durch den kopf oder
manchmal bin ich polizei sagt sie haben
ihre eigene tochter umgebracht ja wenige
mal ich hab gedacht ich
gesagt ich bin die sich auf dem falschen
weg wie war das für sie wenn er
plötzlich die mordkommission
staatsanwalt in der
in einer wohnung ist kapsel machen
lassen und die können wir die ganzen
kopf stellen sie finden im unix und wie
es danach weiter also macht er auch sie
suchen sind sie damit zum polizei da hab
ich dann bis abends um halb sieben
dagewesen und staatsanwalt mal auch bei
und die haben gesagt dass ich meine top
300 euro
soll die polizei recht behalten und hat
johannes teyssen wegen dieser summe
seine eigene tochter auf dem gewissen
oder hat die polizei händeringend nach
einem schuldigen gesucht ich habe den
vater zum teil vernommen ich habe
zumindest die durchsuchung in seiner
wohnung geleitet und ich habe auch ihn
entsprechend belehrt ich habe ihm also
erklärt dass er in den beschuldigten
status gekommen ist dass er nicht sagen
muss dass er ein rechtsanwalt
hinzuziehen kann so der ehemalige
ermittler grusel kalkar erinnert sich an
sein gespräch mit judith vater und
versucht beide seiten der ermittlungen
nachzuvollziehen hatten sie ihn anwalt
eigentlich oder waren sie da saßen sie
da allein ich habe noch gesagt ich
glaube ich muss
die stadien werde ich gesagt ja wir so
anfangen können wir gleich aufhören eine
gute mutter mona anwalt eigentlich auch
keine saubere art und weise zu arbeiten
oder auch nie gesagt wieso darf man
keinen anwalt habe aber okay wir sind
wenn sie wollen gegen braucht kein
anwalt wenn die mindest gegen die
gewesen ist doch gelogen ist doch gar
nicht habe ich gedacht so immer
irgendwie wollte ich mehr verarschen er
ist kriminalpsychologe begutachtet
worden das waren also so verschiedene
merkmale seiner seine handlungsweisen
die eben dazu geführt haben dass man
gesagt hat okay dass es irgendwo und
stimmig sind unstimmigkeiten zumindest
recht verdienen die einen
anfangsverdacht gegen ihn viele von uns
kennen das ja nicht dass man da
plötzlich bei der mordkommission sitzt
wie wo der druck denn da auf sie
aufgebaut gab es da irgendwelche
wladimir angeschrieben
ein betrüger ein mörder da war der da
aufgebaut haben habe ich gesagt um
noch eine dritte perspektive einbeziehen
zu können spricht kein mit der anwältin
des beschuldigten katharina theuerkauf
in einem eleganten blauen kostüm
empfängt ihn die frau mit schulterlangen
glatten haar auch sie ist mit den
einzelheiten der situation bestens
vertraut es ist sicherlich einer meiner
größten fälle aber zumindest einer der
mich in meiner zeit bisher am längsten
begleitet hat welche spuren hatten die
polizei verfolgt die den vater
verdächtig haben blicken lassen mann
ermittelt in solchen fällen sicherlich
immer erst einmal im persönlichen umfeld
das signal und man guckt mit wem hatte
judith zuletzt kontakt das ist dem vater
auf vornehmen nicht gewesen er hat ihr
beim umzug in die neue wohnung geholfen
er hat ihr geholfen die küche einzubauen
es soll finanzielle probleme gegeben
haben weil das bafög gestrichen worden
sein soll das waren alles so punkte die
man dann eben zusammenhang damit dass er
auch den leichnam aufgefunden hat ja
letztendlich dann als anlass genommen
hat die ihn als beschuldigten zu führen
für johannes teyssen eine
ausnahmesituation in einem moment
verliert der mann seine gerade mal
erwachsene tochter in dem anderen muss
er mit dem vorwurf leben diese getötet
zu haben
die haben natürlich mein auto
mitgenommen
auch durchsucht und haben sie nach
feierabend habe ich eben immer frei
damit in meinen augen bei meiner arbeit
auf die hebebühne nach oben hin mein
auto ist mal von unten angebote bewegen
und da haben die da so schwarzer kasten
jetzt bist du schön war wo ich ihnen
gefallen der große warum wurde damals
denn sein wagen geortet wurde auch mein
sender angebracht ja es ist auch so dass
der wagen verteilt worden ist in
irgendeiner weise etwas angebaut worden
sodass man also auch dann per satellit
nachvollzogen hat wo er sich dann mit
dem fahrzeug bewegen
auch von solchen maßnahmen erhofft man
sich ja dann dass man
ja dass der mensch der dann überwacht
wird nochmal ort aufsucht die in
irgendeiner weise relevant sind es hätte
zum beispiel damals sein können das
vielleicht noch mal ein ort aufgesucht
worden wäre wo man die kleidung von ihr
auf gefunden hätte oder andere
gegenstände die noch relevant gewesen
wären und auch abgehört eigentlich so
wie geht man davor wenn du jemand in den
fokus rückt es gab seitens der
staatsanwaltschaft einen beschluss dass
telefonüberwachungen stattfinden soll
auch beim vater das war möglich weil er
beschuldigt an mord verfahren war und
das hat dann auch stattgefunden und
dient dann eben dazu herauszufinden ob
über die tat gesprochen wird der
verdacht hält sich lange doch das
schicksal ist auf johannes teyssen seite
ein plötzlicher fund am tatort verändert
alles während der fahrt schildert ex
ermittler große dem bild reporter die
details
zu haben und plötzlich kommt wie aus dem
nichts
um diese sensationelle wendung zu
verstehen lädt kelkheim den zuständigen
polizei präsidenten herrn dürig 1 dieser
tritt professionell in einem grauen
anzug auf karl heim kommt ihm auf halben
weg entgegen und führt ihn in die
redaktionsräume von bild hannover henry
kennen sie eigentlich alle fälle die in
ihren zuständigkeitsbereich lagen nein
natürlich nicht als polizeipräsident der
polizeidirektion göttingen bin ich für
3.000 mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
zuständig wir haben 72.000 straftaten im
jahr zu bearbeiten
und da kann ich natürlich nicht alle
felder
die haben sich von diesem fall erfahren
bei kapitalverbrechen erfahre ich dass
einer morgendlichen besprechung
dann höre ich mir die grundzüge des
falls ein mehr aber auch nicht von
diesem fall habe ich insbesondere
erfahren weil der vater sich über die
ermittlungsmethoden der polizei niemand
beschwert hat sollen daraufhin habe ich
mir in diesem fall genauer angeschaut
und habe mir von der mordkommission
erklären lassen welche maßnahmen die
getroffen haben und warum sie die
maßnahmen getroffen haben und warum man
das so lange gedauert das doppelt das
waren ja fast fünf monaten die
dazwischen lagen was ist es so dass hier
mehr als 500 beweisstücke sichergestellt
worden den spuren sichergestellt worden
dabei war auch ein kaugummi papier bei
einer weiteren auswertung beim
controlling verfahren hat man
festgestellt man hätte ja auch auf dna
spuren gehen können und im rahmen der
bei trennen dna-untersuchungen bis es
dann zu den hinweis auf den täter
bekommen was konnte man dann
herausfinden also wen konkret diese dna
zugeordnet werden
der sexualstraftäter jörg and out
plötzlich als exakt passendes fehlendes
puzzleteil auf der mann ist mittleren
alters hat dünnes haar und einen leeren
nichtssagenden blick ein mann bei dessen
anblick man lieber die straßenseite
wechselt was waren damals über dem
bekannt über den vermeintlichen täter
aus dem maßregelvollzug war bekannt dass
er schon mehrfach
wer sexualdelikte vorbestraft war dass
er zu viereinhalb jahren verurteilt
worden ist und dass er im anschluss an
eine in einer sicherungsverwahrung gehen
sollte ich will wissen wer ist dieser
tatverdächtige was ist ein blitz letzten
tag passiert wie haben sie sich
kennengelernt was der zufallsbegegnung
ist der mörder und falls ja warum hat er
sie umgebracht
kelkheim und inge mabuse halten auf
einem halb leeren parkplatz vor dem
maßregelvollzugs zentrum mehrere
aneinandergereihte wohnungen sind hier
zu finden auf den ersten blick völlig
harmlos man würde von außen nicht damit
rechnen dass hier schwerverbrecher zu
hause sind sind ja direkt an
maßregelvollzugs zentrum bad rehburg und
zwar genau da hat uns die dna-spur
hingeführt wenn wir jetzt da weiterhin
gehen dann kommen wir da direkt zudem zu
dem eingangsbereich wo man sich dann bei
der ford anmelden muss und wo man dann
auch als polizeibeamter tatsächlich
seine waffe dann abgeben muss was sitzen
da eigentlich im menschen drin also mit
dem haben es da zu tun oder die polizei
das sind nicht einfach nur
kleine ladendiebe sondern es sind im
großen und ganzen durchweg leute die
durch viele straftaten aufgefallen sind
die durch gewaltdelikte aufgefallen sind
durch sexualdelikte aufgefallen sind wo
eine therapie angeordnet wird diese
immer sogenannte maßregel der besserung
und sicherung und das findet dann hier
statt und dann werden die leute aus dem
aus der jva wo sie dann
ihren gefängnisaufenthalt ihre
freiheitsstrafe verbüßen werden sie dann
hierher verlegt und werden dann quasi
aus den abläufen das eines gefängnisses
in die abläufe einer klinik um
gegliedert und daneben ich sag mal aber
schritt für schritt die patienten auch
natürlich die damit der öffentlichkeit
transportiert sie haben ja gesagt dass
er im ersten stock da gewohnt hat also
mir das angucken erste stock hier ist er
das wohnhaus tatsächlich das wohnhaus in
dem judith mit ihrer mutter lebte ist
nur wenige hundert meter von dem zuhause
des vermeintlichen täters entfernt da
oben die kleinen fensterchen das waren
die ihre fenster und hier an der straße
direkt ihre eingangstür das heißt man
kann also wenn man zurückschaut eben
auch aus verschiedensten blickwinkeln
und gebäudetrakt des maßregelvollzugs
mehr oder weniger direkt diesen
eingangsbereiche schon beobachten und
sieht wer da rein und raus geht er hat
auf jeden fall die möglichkeit zu gucken
im rahmen seiner lockerung wenn
jugendlichen lang geht so geht die junge
frau hin wenn er sich frei bewegen
konnte die wichtigste zeugin die jude
zuletzt lebend gesehen hat hat sie auch
mit einem mann im auto gesehen auf ihrem
beifahrersitz
main sid das dass der mann in dem auto
waren denen die zeugin gesehen hat ich
persönlich würde von den tagesabläufen
ausschließen für mich ist objektiv dass
sie erkennen bei ihrem auto gesessen hat
ich würde davon ausgehen dass keiner im
auto gesessen hat wenn man sich mit dem
thema zeugen wahrnehmung beschäftigt
weiß man ja auch dass nicht jede zeugen
wahrnehmung unbedingt tatsächlich so der
wahrheit entsprechen muss ließ sich in
dem geist oder in der änderungen dass
menschen festsetzt um alle facetten des
falles zu beleuchten trifft kelkheim den
verteidiger von jörg m der anwalt ist
ein großgewachsener mann im grauen anzug
in dessen büro besprechen die beiden
männer die aussagen des angeklagten er
werk wie kam die dna an den tatort das
ist bis zum heutigen tage völlig
ungeklärt da konnte auch das konnte auch
die beweisaufnahme keinerlei als punkte
erbringen auf meinen mann dann konnte
mir dazu keine weiteren angaben machen
er selber sagte mir er kaut kein
kaugummi von daher wäre es auch
untypisch dass kaugummi papier seine dna
dreht mein mandant hat gesagt er kennt
wie getötete nicht er hat sie mir
gesehen und hat auch dementsprechend
keinen kontakt zu ihr gehabt wie sah der
tagesablauf ihres mandanten außen können
sie das schild an was hat er das so
gesagt er hatte an diesem tag ausgang
der wahl genehmigt worden für den
stadtbereich wunstorf und seiner
erinnerung nach war er an diesem tag
auch in bohnsdorf mit dem fahrrad und
ist dann um 17 uhr in den
maßregelvollzug zurückgehen johannes
teyssen der vater des opfers wurde vor
dem auffinden des fehlenden beweis
stückes als mörder seiner tochter
beschuldigt nun gibt es einen anderen
schuldigen der gebrochene mann schüttelt
verständnislos den kopf und schaut ein
altes foto seiner tochter an jetzt hat
ihrer tochter ja in unmittelbarer nähe
zu diesem maßregelvollzug gewohnt
kannten sie diese klinik mussten sie
wieder drin war und hatten sie jemals
daran gedacht dass das einer von ihnen
gewesen sein könnte ihre wohnung und
maßregelvollzug anstalt sind ungefähr
1500 meter oder noch nicht mal und wenn
sie dann natürlich zu fuß machen
wer etwas einkaufen will und müssen sich
irgendwie begegnet glauben sie dass sie
noch leben würde wenn sie
wenn sie nicht neben dem maßregelvollzug
gewohnt hätte
hätte diese verbindung nicht zustanden
gekommen und muss daher kommt der hat da
was drin gesehen da wo er sein trikot
wieder auslassen kann mit dem ehemaligen
beamten inge marcuse steht der reporter
vor dem damaligen fenster des
sexualstraftäters aus diesem kleinen
fenster das seinem kammer fenster
gleicht hat er jeden tag hinaus geschaut
hat er sein zukünftiges opfer womöglich
beobachtet war die tat ein geplantes
vergehen oder sind die beiden sich durch
zufall begegnet und hat er seinen trieb
an judith ausgelebt weil sie gerade in
der nähe war wie sah denn der tag von
jacken aus wie kommt der angeklagte
daraus der komm raus in dem man sich
eben in dem gebäudetrakt auf seiner
jeweiligen station im stationszimmer
abmeldet geht dann zum haupteingang raus
er empfängt irgendwo noch sein fahrrad
oder holt das aus irgendwo in einem
schuppen und kann hier durch die durch
die parkanlagen durch die kuranlagen
irgendwo gibt es hier ja verschiedene
fußwege sieht man dann auch zur straßen
kommt was er denn da gemacht hat war ihm
selbst überlassen und er hat sich dann
eben gegen frühen abend irgendwo
zwischen 17 und 18 uhr irgendwann zurück
gemeldet also ist auch noch im rahmen
das ist zeitlich der zeitlichen vorgaben
in der lage gewesen es war sehr
auffällig an dem tag dass er
gesichtsverletzungen zeigte er hat auf
nachfrage dann angegeben dass er durch
büsche gefahren sei er hat auch von
einem sturz geredet er war erschöpft er
hat auch danach ganz ganz ganz lange
geschlafen hat mich geredet also
wahlziele äußerliche auffälligkeiten bei
ihm die anders waren als die gesamten
wochen vorher habe man versucht das zu
rekonstruieren also hat man seinen
versucht seinen weg nach zug sage ich
dann ja also man hat man halt ein
nachvollzogen durch wir durch ein
radfahrer und auch ein fußweg der
sozialwahl zurückgelegt haben von von
hier maßregelvollzug bis zum
leichenfundort und zurück und was bei
rausgekommen also aus sicht von uns
ermittlern war das alles locker zu
schaffen von hier dorthin zu fahren sich
dahin zu begeben da zeit zu haben zu
schauen ist sie denn eventuell und sich
zu orientieren und daneben auch die
leiche zu verstecken entsprechend
zuzudecken und mit dem fahrrad hinterher
zu fahren ist
der tag ist ein schöner tag im
spätsommer es ist sonnig und die 23
jährige judith will den abend mit einem
ruhigen spaziergang im nahegelegenen
kloster wald ausklingen lassen ihr weg
kreuzt den des ehemaligen
sexualstraftäters jörg n der in einer
anstalt in unmittelbarer nähe aus so
lässt sich das geschehen mit den
ermittlungsergebnissen
rekonstruieren er fällt über sie her ein
kampf um leben und tod beginnt er drückt
sie an den schultern zu boden sie
zerkratzten das gesicht doch die junge
frau kommt nicht gegen ihren peiniger an
als judith toth ist versteckt jörg m die
leiche unter einem baum erklärt
pünktlich in sein zuhause zurück es ist
schockierend wie einfach dieses rätsel
eigentlich zu lösen ist doch was waren
die motive des täters
reporter kalk raum wirft einen blick auf
das lange strafregister des
vermeintlichen mörders mit dem finger
geht er die einzelnen straftaten durch
16 399 verurteilung durch das
amtsgericht meppen wegen vergewaltigung
ein jahr ein monat dann geht es weiter
drei cent dritte 2000 verurteilung durch
das landgericht osnabrück wegen
vergewaltigung zu einer freiheitsstrafe
von drei jahren
dazwischen waren immer mal so kleinere
sachen
2012 17 januar vor und dann kriegst auch
ich wegen vergewaltigung in tateinheit
mit sechs entwicklung zu einer
freundschaft von vier jahren und zehn
monaten mit anschließender
sicherungsverwahrung also da hat schon
jemand einiges auf dem kerbholz das
zieht sich durch das ganze leben über
mehrere jahre jahrzehnte
schwerste sexualstraftaten
jetzt erhoffe ich mir dass er durch
professor bandelow der
psychiater und psychologen mit solchen
menschen gearbeitet hat solche menschen
bot was er mir sagt kritik so jemand
also was geht in seinem kopf vor wie ist
so jemand drauf professor bandelow
besucht den reporter in der redaktion
ingo anzughose und feinem weißen hemd
sitzt karl heim in einem sessel
gegenüber eindringlich schaut er diesen
an so als würde gleich die nächste
sitzung starten mit ruhiger stimme
stellte sich vor
von beruf als für neurologie und sich
andré und psychotherapie habe in einer
forensischen psychiatrie gearbeitet und
meine aufgabe war die patientin zu
diagnostizieren und auch zu behandeln
jetzt habe ich ihn was mitgebracht zu
schützen falls das denn seine vorstrafen
aus dem bundeszentralregister auszug
dastehen drin diebstahl sexuelle
nötigung vergewaltigung also das zieht
sich so durchs ganze leben was sagt das
also was sagt das über ein aus also wenn
die man zwei drei vier oder auch mehr
vergewaltigung wir schon begann hat und
dann jeweils auch aus den haftstrafen
nichts gelernt hat oder einen
sogenannten bewährungsversager ist dann
will bei mir alle alarmglocken ist der
mann gefährlich ich kenne den
betroffenen nicht und deswegen kann ich
da nicht viel zu sagen aber ich denke
aufgrund der vorstrafen muss man da
schon davon ausgehen dass es eine sehr
hohe gefährdung ist und deswegen hat man
ja auch diese sicherungsverwahrung
im urteil ausgesprochen
damit würden sie den einschätzen als er
vermutlich viele solcher menschen schon
begutachtet
und befragt wie ticken wie was geht da
im kopf von solchen menschen vor
es geht letztlich um macht es geht
manchmal gar nicht um sex sondern um
macht man möchte die ultimative
kontrolle über jemanden haben man möchte
wie gottes sozusagen herr über leben und
tod seien und man möchte auch dass diese
machtausübung sozusagen
quittiert wird in dem das opfer angst
sagt was hat so ein mann für den
krankheits belieben sie den beschreiben
ist dass sadisten psychopath in einem
früheren gerichtsurteil wurde er ja
schon ein gutachter als sexueller sadist
bezeichnet das ist jemand der also nicht
nur gefallen daran findet sexual ab
gegen den willen der betroffenen
auszuüben sondern eben auch
freude daran empfinden wenn das opfer
gequält und gefoltert wird ich habe
herausgefunden dass er mehrfach feiert
war mehrere kinder hat wie passt so was
zusammen dass frauen so einen menschen
zusammen sein können merkt man das
vielleicht als frau gar nicht oder kann
ist ja manipulativ es gibt straftäter
die eben auf der einen seite sexuelle
sadisten sind auf der anderen seite aber
auch frauen einen gewissen charme
ausüben können unbedingt auch ganz
normale beziehungen haben wird da zum
beispiel an jack unterweger einem
berühmten serienmörder der sehr viele
frauen beziehungen hatte und dann zum
beispiel den einvernehmlichen sex mit
einer frau hatte dann mitten in der
nacht nochmal aufgestanden ist und dann
eine prostituierte ermordet hat das hat
der völlig getrennt auf der einen seite
konnte tatsächlich der liebhaber sein
auf der anderen seite wollte eben auch
ein opfer am morgen wobei es ihm gar
nicht um sex ging sondern um die
gewalten um die machtausübung
[Musik]
schwer zu fassen bleibt wie die polizei
bei diesem fall versagt hat die lösung
liegt die ganze zeit auf der hand und
trotzdem tappen die ermittelnden wochen
und monate im dunkeln der ehemalige
polizeibeamte guse und polizeipräsident
lürig besuchen erklärungen wir hatten
damals relativ früh die spur
maßregelvollzug und der ich selber sogar
beteiligt war es war natürlich bekannt
dass der maßregelvollzug da ein
entsprechendes potenzial an menschen
beherbergt natürlich war uns auch als
ein polizei klar dass da entsprechendes
gewaltpotenzial da ist wir haben alle
namen aufgeführt derer die überhaupt im
maßregelvollzug erstmal zu der zeit
stationiert waren und haben dann zum
beispiel auch selektiert wer ist wegen
sexualstraftaten schon mal in
erscheinung getreten und wer hat zum
beispiel davon freigang es gab also eine
offizielle vernehmung eines
stellvertretenden klinikleiter dort hat
er keine konkreten hinweise gegeben im
anschluss in einem lockeren gespräch an
die vernehmung hat er dann mitgeteilt
das ist eine person gehabt die von einem
fahrradausflug zurückgekommen ist mit
kratzspuren im gesicht und ein kollege
das aufgenommen für sich persönlich hat
das aber vergessen in die personen spur
bei so einem fall mit 1 zu geben das ist
ein fehler der polizei
kann ich auch gemacht worden ist dass
auch nachbereitet worden und aufbereitet
worden ich sage auch heute noch das war
einer der drastischsten fehler der im
rahmen dieser ermittlungen der polizei
unterlaufen ist wie kann es sein dass so
jemand der eigentlichen und
sicherungsverwahrung verurteilt ist die
angeordnet wurde dass du jemanden
brauchst doch das kann ich ihnen auch
nicht erklären da müsste man sich an das
sozialministerium
bänden die sind für diesen bereich des
maßregelvollzugs zuständig ich habe
dafür kein verständnis
gesagt getan
auch mit dem ministerium beschäftigt
sich der bild-reporter und schaut sich
nochmal die wortmeldung der damaligen
niedersächsischen sozialministerin
cornelia runter ich möchte sie heute
unterrichten
gestern am 14 april 2016 wurde gegen
einen patienten des maßregelvollzugs
zentrums bad rehburg untersuchungshaft
angeordnet des weiteren wurde ein besuch
und beschlagnahmebeschluss erlassen der
patient wird verdächtigt im september
2015 eine junge frau getötet zu haben
also müssen die aufnahme von ministerin
rund damals so sieht dann gewinnt man
schon den eindruck als würde man sich
dann rechtfertigen wollen dann würde man
sich schon quasi vorab entschuldigen
wollen die klinik teilt mit dass es
während der unterbringung zu keinen
regelverstössen gekommen ist so genannte
lockerungen das heißt maßnahmen bei
denen sich der patient zunächst in
begleitung bewegen durfte gab es seit
2003 10
ende 2014 hat nicht nur die interne
lockerungs konferenz sondern eine
externe prognose kommission bestehend
aus drei experten auch unbegleitete
lockerungen für den patienten empfohlen
diese lockerung wurden von der
staatsanwaltschaft genehmigt und dann
schrittweise durchgeführt
es ist der letzte prozesstag im fall
judith theissen der gerichtssaal füllt
sich langsam
der vater des opfers die anwälte und
schließlich auch jürgen trittin ein
der angeklagte sitzt mit leerem blick im
gerichtssaal er schweigt zu allem was
man ihm vorwirft
auf den ersten blick wirkt er nicht
aggressiv und fällt kaum auf doch wie
konnte man aus den augen verlieren wer
dieser mensch war und was für eine
gefahr von ihm ausging ingo kruse und
auch johannes teyssen haben einen klaren
standpunkt dazu
erstmal ist ja eine verfügte
sicherungsverwahrung einfach so außer
kraft gesetzt worden sie hat durch ich
sage mal die therapie abläufe hier
völlig entkräftet worden es ist
angeordnet worden dass der mensch
aufgrund seiner gefährlichkeit kein
zugang zur öffentlichkeit mehr haben
soll möglicherweise lebenslang nicht
mehr deshalb sicherungsverwahrung und
hier im rahmen dieser therapie sieht er
wieder in die öffentlichkeit gelassen
und das ja nicht nur aus versehen
sondern im grunde genommen vorsätzlich
sicherlich der größte fehler gemacht
haben eigentlich antik meine tochter
umgebracht weil er da draußen herum
gekommen ist dass sie gesagt haben okay
war schon gut mitgemacht lukas mal ein
bisschen draussen obenauf man könnte
sogar behaupten
diese mörder der der kann der eigentlich
so ein mann ist krank
er hat sie nicht alle aber wenn wenn das
bekannt ist und die setzten den dollar
fest
sicherheitsverwahrung darf nicht mehr
auf die straße und da kommt eine und
lässt ihn laufen
der hatten trinkt das muss erst wenn der
dann rauskommt dann musste ein ausleben
gegen die anders da muss ein versuch so
lange bis er eine findet die ihr kennt
und das handy wieder verteidigen kann
das hat sich damals keiner wurde bei der
polizei gemeldet ganz im gegenteil es
ist in verschiedenen vernehmung deutlich
geworden dass da personal oder teile des
personals ein bauchgefühl hatten mehr
oder weniger eine böse vorahnung hatten
das eben genau der mann der täter
gewesen ist das aber niemand sich
getraut hat darüber mit der polizei zu
sprechen yamana gedacht da es gewesen
die in den maßregelvollzug die haben
doch die haben auch zwei jugendliche
aber auch fernsehen geguckt und die
haben auch ohne beständig gewusst dass
er in bad rehburg die junge frau
verschwunden ist und der kommt mit
kratzer drin wieder rein
und so machen wir das nicht weiter
gegeben ihre meinung das weiß keiner was
ist falsch gelaufen war nicht nur hoffen
kann ja es sind für mich sind mittäter
also nicht mutwillig aber im laufen
lassen auch sagen wir machen wollen sind
willkommen der sau raus nein genau sind
ja behalten
so was
ich bin davon überzeugt wenn jörg m
in haft geblieben wäre wäre noch am
leben nun mussten sterben weil in der
bundesrepublik deutschland und speziell
in sachsen entspannte faire abstimmung
zwischen justiz und sozialministerium
bestehen judith tyson wurde im september
2015 im kloster wald ermordet
sechseinhalb jahre später wird das
endgültige urteil des richters am
landgericht osnabrück gefällt
der angeklagte wird wegen mordes zu
einer lebenslangen freiheitsstrafe
verurteilt außerdem ordnete das gericht
die sicherungsverwahrung an weil der
mann eine gefahr für die allgemeinheit
ist endlich ist das urteil gefällt auch
dass die ganze region gewartet hat ein
urteil das einem trauernden vater
zumindest ein wenig hoffnung auf
gerechtigkeit gibt nach sechseinhalb
jahren ist der mörder ihrer tochter
endlich verurteilt was geht einem durch
den kopf ja dass man endlich seine ruhe
hat und das war nicht abschließen können
behörden versuchen in der regel immer
abzublocken wir haben keinen fehler
gemacht uns trifft keine schuld
verstecken sich hinter floskeln wie
laufendes verfahren dazu können wir
nichts sagen meiner meinung nach steht
man sich da aus der verantwortung und es
geht immer noch um ein menschenleben es
ist jemand ums leben gekommen denn ich
hätte sterben dürfen der fall mahnt uns
daran dass wohl eines straftäters und
seine resozialisierung nicht über die
sicherheit der gesellschaft zu stellen
er sollte ermittler darin bestärken auf
alle beweise zu achten und sie ernst zu
nehmen an dieser stelle verabschiede ich
mich von euch bis zum nächsten mal neues
kino ganz klar das hätte man verhindern
können der mann hätte ihn niemals raus
gedurft und mein job ist es
dranzubleiben so etwas aufzudecken und
dann bestmöglich das dann auch
veränderung damit einhergehender klar
und das ist unser job
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus in wake world studios
projektleitung simone der bank
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
nadja goldhammer redaktion bild karl
keil und stefan metzen bank